I have been so nervous about today I
literally have not been sleeping all
week if it wasn't driving today probably
would need a drink do you guys do you
want do you want to drive so we can get
a little little cocktail somewhere when
we arrive no but seriously it's been
like 20 years since I've be back today
we're on the road heading back to my
hometown in Peterboro where I'm going to
be eating like I did in high school aka
before the diet culture days it's going
to be fun probably not a lot of
vegetables but it's going to be fun
[Music]
super quick here folks I really want to
talk about my sponsor today hom glob so
I'm a super organized person but I'm a
very messy person and this is quite the
Dilemma for me because I cannot feel
organized when things are messy so I
really appreciate the value of having
someone with actual cleaning skills who
like sees a pile and puts it away to
comeon lend some much needed support so
homow is a five-star cleaning service
with super affordable prices way cheaper
than most services that I've paid for in
the past and definitely worth it to save
my marriage and my ability to get work
done but the way it works is you go to
homog Glow's website to choose the day
and time that you're looking for and the
duration of your cleaning and you'll be
able to see all the available cleaners
along with their background checks
photos and reviews so if you have
someone that you've worked with before
you can rebook that same person
and you can schedule it for that week or
like a month from now if you want to
rebook your cleanings on a regular basis
you can also sign up for their forever
clean membership which saves you $30 an
hour on future cleanings or unlimited
cleanings for $19 an hour all of which
are backed by their happiness guarantee
and the cleaners are really super
incentivized to do a good job because
100% of the cleaning fees and tips go
directly to them I don't know about you
but I just feel like I can work so much
more effic efficiently and calmly when
I'm not living in chaos take home
cleaning off your plate using homag glow
head to homag glow.com abyar or scan the
QR code to get your first 3 hours of
cleaning for only
$19
country take me
home I don't belong there anymore
C
Peter we're just driving past and we had
to check out my old elementary school
I was here since grade 5
through grade eight I guess and my
strongest
memory was going to the dance the school
dance and you know dancing like this was
it like this no hands up
here it's basically all I got simple
times oh Pizza day yeah Pizza day was
the best so that was my house the trees
are gotten a lot lot bigger than I feel
like I remember and in my head of course
as a small child the house is much
bigger as well but it was a very nice
little place to to grow up it was super
quiet and our friends down the street I
could just like run down the street and
knock on their door and be like hey do
you want to play we make up some kind of
like make b games but like we were
animals or aliens or something going on
maybe the Spice
[Music]
Girls but yeah it's a simple time and
honestly in high school I don't think I
recall ever having breakfast at home we
were teenagers we rushed out the door we
had to get out really early cuz my mom
worked next door to school so I
basically always ate my breakfast at
school and I'm going to show you what
were some of my favorites when we get
there I knew there was a reason I left
this place what the is that come on
Brody getting out of
[Music]
here so weird so so weird to be back
I mean it's literally been 20 years it's
not actually a school anymore which is
too bad because it was like one of the
oldest schools in the area established
1827 I think it says but I have a lot of
good memories and a lot of not so good
memories this school actually had a
little bit of an arts program so I was
an Arts student and therefore I was a
bit of a misfit I guess I still kind of
am bit of a weirdo and yeah people were
just not always kind to us art students
even our my teachers used to make fun of
us my science teacher used to make fun
of me calling me an artsy fartsy or
whatever and now that I am a Scientist
yes science I kind of want to call him
up and say Hey you know you shouldn't
count on me out because you know Arts
kids can do great things in science too
but yeah these were definitely simpler
times when it came to
food because I'm pretty sure I started
my day every morning not with a balanced
breakfast but I would come to the
cafeteria I'd get chocolate milk and I'd
get a chocolate chip cookie oh and these
ones are not bad looking this is
obviously not from the cafeteria but the
calf cookies were like as big as my head
and they were very undercooked and
literally just raw in the middle and to
my knowledge none of us ever got sick I
mean I don't know how that would fly
today but they were so so so good oh
they were like that big and we would
just eat a cookie for breakfast have our
chocolate milk and if the cookies were
not ready in
time I would literally eat sour skittles
for breakfast while watching the boys
play
basketball so yeah Breakfast of
Champions
here I mean this one's good I haven't
drank chocolate milk in years my kids
are obsessed with it I'm not mad about
this little breakfast snack here
M it is very very yummy but my teeth
already hurt just thinking about the
Skittles and I cannot believe I just
would eat this at like 7 in the morning
before school even
started
oh I'm sorry for you guys who love candy
this is not it for me bro no
skills all yours baby you know my mom
had a really LAX approach to food which
obviously I'm very very grateful for I
know without a doubt that my eating
disorder had nothing to do with my
family because they were not alond moms
or dads they were never pushing like you
know any kind of restriction onto us and
they were totally fine with us having
chocolate milk and cookies and Skittles
for breakfast if we're you know we're
old enough to make our own decisions and
these were the decisions that we made
yeah I kind of would end up getting to
school earlier than most people because
my mom worked
here she didn't work for the Army it's
now like a I guess an army base um and
it always was an Armory but she owned a
montauri school which kind of was
operating out of the armories there and
I always did a lot of the before and
after care for all the kids so I taught
private music lessons for them there um
I did kind of like the daycare I helped
clean I helped organize it was yeah it
was a really nice way to grow up and
um kind of dip my toes into into taking
care of kids which obviously I have a
passion for today too well let's go for
a little walk downtown and I'll show you
some of the places that my friends and I
used to go for lunch a I was so looking
forward to having pets so one of our
favorite places to go for lunch in high
school was this place that was called
pets and basically was like a submarine
shop and I would eat a whole foot long
submarine with like meat and cheese and
whatever else mayo and get these like
really amazing spicy curly fries and to
me that was just like a perfect balanced
meal right like I I had my carbs I had
my my protein I had my fat had my fun my
fries and yeah like there was no calorie
counting there wasn't me thinking in my
head oh if I have the cheese I can't
have the fries oh if I have the fries I
can't have a full sandwich I need to
have half a sandwich oh I should only
have a few fries there was never any of
that food chatter right I ordered and I
ate what felt good to my body and Pete's
definitely felt good but anyways I'm
hoping some of my old stomping grounds
are still around so let's keep hunting
so as a narty fartsy as they called us
we would spend a lot of after hours in
the neighborhood you know we would have
a lot of rehearsals for different shows
we were doing talent shows I mean my
favorite memory performance-wise from
high school maybe in total from high
school was the time that we had a talent
show my best friend and I actually like
all of our friends decided to put on the
VMA madon and Britney kissing situation
naturally I was Britney and my best
friend who was gay he played Madonna and
he did a fabulous job and we had the
best time and we made out on stage in
front of everyone including my boyfriend
my mom all of our teachers and I got a
little for it but you know so did britne
and Madonna and I learned from a very
young age that if you're not pushing
boundaries and if you're not making some
people mad you're probably not making an
impact at all so yeah on Long rehearsal
days we would literally come out here
downtown petero to a parking lot go to
the No Frills get ourselves a half price
baguette some hummus for protein and
then of course a little deep and
delicious because I think they were like
$2 at the
time I can see why it's 50% off little
little tough little tough also I just
realized I don't have a fork
so Savage I know give him one quick
whisk
[Music]
here you want some
brother no this is a private private
private cake then I suppose and I've put
my little fingers in
there dreams and beans dreams of beans
we called it dreams and beans I think
it's dreams of beans but I'm just so
happy it is still here I mean I was very
disappointed about the Pete situation
but dreams of beans I literally had
dreams about so when I was growing up my
father was very very busy he was
studying to get his PhD then he became a
professor and so I spent most of my
daytime with my mom because she worked
next door to us going to school but it
was really always such a treat when my
dad came downtown and took me out for
lunch and by lunch I mean cake because
we literally went to the cafe and just
had a slice of cake for lunch and
there's a specific cake in my mind that
I still dream about cuz it was that good
had like honeycomb on the side I'm just
praying that they still have it this is
that this is going to make my whole year
my whole life and I maybe can finally
put all of these obsess of High School
Dreams to bed if I could just have this
cake dreams of beans don't let me down
okay so I got a little iced tea cuz that
was a staple when I was growing up I
didn't drink coffee until I don't know
maybe University and they didn't have my
cake so I'm just going to have to keep
dreaming about it apparently just haunts
me in my dream this like little
honeycomb crunch on the sides and this
like really sweet buttercream was so
good I got to meditate on it but I still
want to support local business so I got
this Cinnamon Toast Crunch I don't know
marshmallow treat uh I'm very excited to
dig into this I'm also going to have to
save most of it for Brody and my kids
which they're one and the same Brody
isn't to my children m m this cinnamon
that just hits different oh little spicy
so good and I know a lot of you guys are
probably thinking like how could your
parents let you just eat cake for lunch
but I'm actually so grateful for those
experience for a number of reasons I
mean once we get older especially as
teenagers we don't tend to spend as much
quality time with our parents and I'm so
glad that I got to have those
experiences with my dad without them
being clouded by diet culture that was
like our special little thing that
crunchy honeycomb cake and I'm also so
grateful that I wasn't raised by my
parents pushing these moral messages
around food you know where cake wasn't
bad and apples weren't good I don't
remember my parents ever using any kind
of language like that they served
generally balanced meals as best as my
mom could and you know they saw us as
young adults able to make our own
decisions when we're out and about with
our friends and if I had cake for lunch
I was probably going to want vegetables
or some fruit at dinner when I got home
from the school but yeah my parents
tried their damn best without even
knowing it to protect me from diet
Culture by allowing me to have this
flexibility by allowing me to make
mistakes by allowing me to explore my
body's needs Etc without any kind of
guilt or shame it was all the other
competing messages around me that
actually did the damage okay so it
wouldn't be a day in my life as a high
schooler without going to the mall
because as a teenager there wasn't a
whole lot else to do other than to go to
the mall after school at least not
lately but whether whether or not we had
dinner with our parents later on which
we usually did we would always have to
stop by the food court for a snack so
I'm going to show you what I would
usually get all right
folks pre- dinner or dinner is served so
this is basically a schmorgus borg of
some of the things I used to order when
I come to the food court fries of course
just straight up like this would be the
whole meal slash snack here we got a
chicken SE Cesar wrap which I mean I
still love me a chicken Caesar wrap
today but again this was definitely my
idea of being like a super super healthy
choice and then Chinese food but
interestingly I would only ever get the
vegetable low man I never would get any
of the meat or the veg on the side but
again knowing so little about nutrition
and caring so little about nutrition
vegetable l Main was like a very very
healthy choice to me because it was
vegetarian and vegetarian equated to
healthfulness and it's so interesting to
see now how messaging has changed and
we've adapted so many different specific
ideas about what constitutes healthiness
but anyways the Chinese restaurant
didn't even sell on its Lonesome and I'm
grateful for that so I got it as a combo
with some veg which I desperately need
right
now broccoli broccoli Just Hits
different when you've had cookies and
like a cereal bar for breakfast
but you know being in this place I have
to say feels so familiar like it looks
very different than it did when I was
growing up but the feeling is the same
and I think the reason why high school
years had such a heavy imprint on me
like I literally dream about high school
every night I don't know why but I can't
shake it but I think it's because my
life just felt so much bigger then so
much bigger in the years before diet
culture took its hold when I wasn't
thinking about how many calories were in
something when I wasn't hating my body
when I wasn't trying to think of how
many calories I could burn by dancing I
was just dancing because I was having
fun and enjoying it and enjoying life
like my world just felt so much bigger
before I knew that much about nutrition
like the relationships the parties the
late nights the trouble just the fun you
know it was just such a simple time and
I guess I just have a lot of nostalgia R
it because of the trauma that I
experienced basically immediately coming
out of high school and tumbling into a
KN disorder and having to work so hard
to get myself out so hard to be able to
see the fries and the low man noodles
and the chicken Caesar wrap and think it
doesn't matter like food is food is food
is food and at the end of the day I know
my body today and it wouldn't feel good
just having fries at as a
snack oh but these fries are damn good
salty but really really
good okay last nostalgic pit stop before
we hit the road I had to go and get a
blue Slurpee so this used to be a
7-Eleven and we used to come here with
our $5 a week allowance walk you know on
the busy road get our Slurpee and then
just like sit on a curb so let's go
stretch our legs relax a minute before
I've got a drive home in track they also
had cheese curds randomly so I had to
get those
obviously oh sweet it tastes like one of
those
coolers that you drink when you were
young but without the alcohol which is
probably even worse I just have a few
final thoughts here because I know that
a lot of my followers are you know teens
and young adults and I just want you to
take one very important thing away from
this video do not diet you know
adolescence and childhood is not a time
to be restricting in any capacity I mean
ideally we don't get into dieting at any
age or phase of the life cycle but
childhood and Adolescence is a time of
rapid growth and bodily Discovery and as
an elder Millennial I have to say that
my relationship with food growing up was
very different than a lot of teens today
because a you know our parents didn't
know a lot about nutrition like a lot of
parents do today so you know like the
whole alond mom thing they existed but
they certainly weren't what they are
today and B most importantly we didn't
have social media like bombarding us
nonstop with die culture rhetoric and
food fear mongering and yes the 2000s
were unkind in pop culture but
thankfully my exposure to that was at
the end of my adolescent years and also
just could never be as pervasive as
social media you know I really really
truly believe that as parents our job is
to try to expose our kids to as many
different types of foods without any
kind of morality attached we shouldn't
be teaching our young kids how to
identify different versions of sugar or
toxic ingredients on the back of
packaging when you're at the grocery
store like some Wellness influencers do
for their kids these days like that
shouldn't be a flex and obviously as
you've seen today a lot of the foods
that I ate while I was at school with my
friends and buddies weren't necessarily
the most nutritious but because they
were never put on a pedestal or given
any moral weight or restricted I never
felt like I had to overeat them when I
got the chance nothing was off limits in
my childhood and I'm really grateful for
that it wasn't until I left my parents
home and I finished high school and I
kind of like left that food neutral
bubble and I was exposed to the rest of
diet culture that things really went
down Sou but I'm very very confident
that had I never been exposed to dieting
After High School I would have never
become as obsessed over nutrition as I
did which of course was what fed into my
e disorder and for people who are seeing
all of the quote unquote junk food I ate
in high school I'm happy to report that
I don't eat low man for lunch every
single day I'm not addicted to Blue
Slurpees as you can see I don't even
want to drink this I'm going to bring it
home and give it to my husband cuz I
know he will so if you are a young
person watching this please take this as
a cautionary tail there is so much more
to life than just numbers and calories
and macros and portions and you know
body weight your world becomes so so
small when you're obsessing over the
calories in a pack of Caesar dressing if
you're interested in nutrition and of
course I encourage you to be that's why
you're here that's why I encourage you
to be here try to think about counting
colors not calories and hold on to that
innate body wisdom for as long as you
can well folks my husband's been calling
me and probably needs some support so on
that note I'm going to hit the road I've
got lots of leftovers and little treats
to bring for my kiddos and hubby and I
hope you guys enjoyed this video it was
really fun and nostalgic for me to come
back for the first time in 20 years so
if you guys like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with your thoughts what you
thought was healthy or unhealthy when
you were a young person and how that's
changed over the years I think this is
all really interesting stuff and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye